vor 35 Jahren sollte ein
wirtschaftliches Experiment in den USA
und im Vereinigten Königreich ein
besseres Leben für alle ermöglichen
heute ist die Ungleichheit in beiden
Ländern auf dem höchsten Stand seit 1928
[Musik]
ich bin Einzelkind ich hatte eine
großartige Kindheit ich hatte zwei tolle
Eltern die mir alles gegeben haben was
ich brauchte
ich dachte ich könnte fliegen als ich
jung war ich meine wir waren arm aber da
war so viel Liebe dass wir das gar nicht
richtig gemerkt haben
wie früher wir sind in einer Umgebung
aufgewachsen in der wir nie wirklich
wussten was passieren würde und das
schafft eine Menge Unsicherheit
hätte im Vergleich zu früheren
Generationen sind wir vielleicht ein
bisschen Klamm wir können uns vielleicht
nicht das beste Paar Schuhe leisten aber
wir leben nicht in Armut
wir verdienen sehr viel Geld wirklich
sehr viel Geld es ist ja nicht so dass
wir im Lotto gewonnen haben und denn ein
großes schickes Viertel gezogen sind
meine integrität ist das was ich habe
wissen Sie vor langer Zeit hat die
Integrität der Leute noch was bedeutet
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich in den Appalachen
aufgewachsen
wir hatten schöne Weihnachtsfeste wir
hatten liebe ich war normal
aber jetzt
was zum Teufel bin ich jetzt
[Musik]
können sie mich hören
keine Herausforderung ist dringlicher
wir können uns entweder mit einem Land
abfinden in dem es eine schrumpfenden
Zahl von Menschen wirklich gut geht
während eine wachsende Zahl kaum über
die Runden kommt oder wir können eine
Wirtschaft wiederherstellen in der jeder
eine faire Chance bekommt jeder seinen
fairen Beitrag leistet und jeder nach
dem gleichen Regeln spielt
[Applaus]
Staaten sind mit einer wirtschaftlichen
Notlage von großem Ausmaß konfrontiert
es ist an der Zeit diesen
Industriegiganten wieder zu erwecken die
Regierung wieder auf ihre Mittel zu
beschränken und unsere Steuerlast zu
verringern bei diesem Grundsätzen wird
es keine Kompromisse geben
sie zurück an die Arbeit oder nicht
der Betriebsrat hat den Krieg erklärt
wieder ein Arbeitskampf diesmal sind es
die Lastwagenfahrer was zu Panikkäufen
in den Geschäften und auf den Märkten
führt man hatte das Gefühl dass das auch
immer die Regierung zu tun versuchte die
Dinge nicht gerade besser machte es
könnte die Dinge sogar noch schlimmer
machen ich war der Meinung dass der
freie Markt die Ressourcen hervorbringen
würde mit denen es allen besser gehen
könnte die man weiß wenn du das oder das
machst sind die Arbeitslosigkeit dann
gibt es mehr Investitionen und mehr
Einkommen das nach unten hat
ohne große Belohnungen werden Leute wie
ich nicht 15 bis 20 Stunden pro Tag
arbeiten
zu können
[Musik]
das ist schlecht
wurde mir gesagt dass Psychologen die
seit fünf bis zehn Jahren praktizieren
durchschnittlich 100.000 Dollar im Jahr
verdienen und ich dachte das klingt mies
das war eine Art Ansporn für mich zu den
oberen 1% zu gehören
nicht zu den obersten 1% der Welt wir in
der Welt der Psychologie
ich habe mir das ausgesucht ich fahre
lieber ich könnte einen Zug nehmen
direkt in die Stadt aber dann würde ich
vielleicht krank werden wenn ich mit all
diesen fremden Menschen in einem
geschlossenen Raum bin in der
Öffentlichkeit
an diesem Punkt meiner Karriere kann ich
es mir nicht leisten krank zu werden
jeder Tag zählt wenn ich das Haus
abbezahlen will
jetzt noch 10 Minuten um mit dem Kaffee
in der Hand zur Arbeit zu gehen
ich hole mir meinen Kaffee mit
espresso-schorte und gehe mit meinem
Rollkoffer direkt ins Büro
normalerweise bin ich um 5 Uhr
ich mache das Licht an setz mich hin und
dann geht's los bang bang bang eine
Sitzung nach der anderen
so geht das nonstop ich kann diese
kleine Kiste von einem Büro nicht
verlassen ich habe niemanden mit dem ich
reden kann ich muss das Gebäude nie
verlassen außer zum Mittagessen dann
sitze ich da alleine an einem Tresen in
einem Restaurant auf der anderen
Straßenseite und das ist für mich der
Himmel wenn ich die New York Post lese
[Musik]
und wieder unterwegs
der Montag beginnt sonntags und endet
erst am darauf folgenden Freitag sobald
der Montag kommt geht's los jeden Tag
jeden Tag
es ist ein ständiger Kampf alles macht
ein bisschen Stress
ich sag's dir noch einmal
lass das da drin
mach es zu
wenn ich in richtigen stress-modus
gerate rauche ich zu viel was weiß ich
aber
du kannst bei der Arbeit ja nicht
trinken
wenn das möglich wäre hätte ich einen
Flachmann dabei
wir haben Kartoffelecken oder grüne
Bohnen oder Mais oder Macaroni und Käse
Makkaroni und Käse
Kartoffelspalten oder grüne Bohnen
und was ist mit Kartoffelpüree können
sie sich nicht einfach entscheiden was
sie nehmen ich versuche ihnen zu helfen
ich sag's ja nur er hilft mir
please alles ist gut es ist nur so oh
man weißt du mach mal piept
mehr als jeder vierte Mann ist
arbeitslos letzte Woche wurden weitere
600 Entlassungen angekündigt
die Einkommensunterschiede haben sich
seit Mitte der 80er Jahre rapide
vergrößert je schwächer die
Gewerkschaften sind desto mehr
Ungleichheit gibt es das ist ein sehr
auffälliger Zusammenhang
die Arbeitslosen von heute sind die
Opfer der Fehler von gestern aber das
ist Vergangenheit die Regierung drückt
die Inflation senkt die Zinsen
reformiert das gewerkschaftsrecht baut
Vorschriften und Einschränkungen ab
[Applaus]
[Musik]
macht Gleichgewicht zwischen
Arbeitgebern und Arbeitnehmern hat sich
zugunsten der Arbeitgeber verschoben so
ist das gewesen und ich glaube das war
ein bewusstes Ergebnis der Politik
[Musik]
er ist noch im Bett wenn ich morgens zur
Arbeit gehe und er ist wahrscheinlich
schon im Bett wenn ich abends von der
Arbeit komme und wenn nicht wenn er noch
wach ist dann gehe ich wahrscheinlich eh
bald schlafen
[Musik]
die Kinder sind meist noch im Bett wenn
ich zur Arbeit gehe
und wenn ich dann nach Hause komme gehen
sie wieder schlafen
und ich weiß dass das Leben das sie
haben langweilig ist weil sie nicht viel
machen können
[Musik]
in der häuslichen Pflege ist nicht
sicher so wie es läuft weiß man einfach
nicht was von Woche zu Woche vom Tag zu
Tag passiert ich stelle Ihnen das hier
mal hin vor sich das ist heiß lassen Sie
es erstmal ein bisschen abkühlen
wenn jemand stirbt oder ins Krankenhaus
kommt ist das furchtbar aber man denkt
auch an sich selbst wenn man viele
Stunden verliert wenn man nicht etwas
findet um diese Lücke zu füllen kann ich
sonst noch etwas für sie tun nein alles
gut nochmals vielen Dank
sehen wir uns morgen ja morgen früh
komme ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
später
Menschen werden als kaufeinheiten
betrachtet niedrigsten Beta verkauft
werden eine halbe Stunde um jemanden
aufzurichten ihn zu waschen anzuziehen
in die Medikamente zu geben und ein
sinnvolles Gespräch zu führen das geht
nicht
ich werde hier 20 25 Minuten brauchen
die Leute gucken auf deine Schulden ist
das alles was sie tun nein das ist nicht
alles was ich tue ich bin eine
Betreuerin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir sind dorthin gezogen wo mein Mann
herkommt
und wir wollten unser eigenes Geschäft
aufbauen und so das war als wir anfing
kauften wir eine Videothek und als
Walmart ins Videogeschäft eingestiegen
ist hat das den kleinen Läden den Garaus
gemacht
hatte
dann haben wir noch fünf Jahren nicht
gemacht
eines Tages war ich in Walmart und sie
hatten ein Schild auf dem stand dass die
Leute einstellen und ich dachte mir naja
du kannst dich ja bewerben
als sie dann anriefen war ich wirklich
überrascht und ich war sogar noch mehr
überrascht wie gut es war in diesem
Unternehmen zu arbeiten die Manager
kamen rein und sagten ich habe gesehen
was du getan hast hey ich danke dir
bis die Veränderungen kamen die das
Unternehmen wollte die Betriebskosten
senken weniger Leute die die Arbeit
machen aber trotzdem die gleiche Menge
an Arbeit du musst auch gleich los oh ja
es ist 2 Uhr ich glaube ich gehe heute
um 4 Uhr nein 3:30 Uhr heute ist der 4
siehst du jeden Tag geht das so um wie
viel Uhr muss ich zur Arbeit das ist
einfach nervenaufreibend
und ich bin nicht die einzige ich habe
mit Leuten im ganzen Land gesprochen und
bei denen ist es das gleiche sie fragen
sich wann muss ich morgen zur Arbeit sie
glauben gar nicht wie viel Stress das
macht
[Musik]
wir leben in einer Zeit der absolut
erstaunlichen Veränderung sie alle
wissen dass die Informations- und
technologieexplosion ihnen und den
jungen Menschen der Zukunft mehr
Möglichkeiten und Herausforderungen
bieten wird als jede Generation von
Amerikanern je erlebt hat
[Musik]
ein Börsenboom wie es ihnen seitdem
berauschenden 80ern nicht mehr gegeben
hat
Dow Jones ist in nur 12 Monaten umfasst
ein Viertel gestiegen mit Rekordgewinnen
und Millionen Boni auf dem
Gehaltsschecks
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hat ist das wenn Sie früher
Geschäftsführer waren und dann war das
ein Unternehmen auf dem lokalen Markt
heute sind die meisten Märkte die
wichtig sind global ausgerichtet
sind und das Unternehmen um 3 %
effizienter machen haben sie den Gewinn
des Unternehmens um 1,2 Milliarden
Dollar gesteigert wirtschaftlich
explosionsartig wir sind wirklich
erfreut zu berichten dass wir in diesem
Quartal 106 Millionen Dollar verdient
haben
[Applaus]
Bill Gates von Microsoft ist jetzt 29
Milliarden Dollar wert 10 Milliarden
mehr wurden more von Intel Computing 6,7
Milliarden + 3 Milliarden und Bill
hewlet von julit Packard ein
persönliches Vermögen von 4 Milliarden
plus eine Milliarde alles in nur 6
Monaten
wenn sie an der Spitze dieses Prozesses
landen dann haben sie eine
Rechtfertigung für das was mit dem Markt
passiert der ein effizienter Weg ist
Ressourcen zu verteilen
er hat mir eine Menge Ressourcen
zugeteilt also muss ich ein effizientes
Ergebnis abliefern eine Fischen es muss
zeigen dass ich fleißig und klug bin und
in Anführungszeichen verdienen was ich
bekomme
nur sehr wenige Menschen haben die
geistigen Ressourcen die Energie
ich meine sehen Sie mich an ich baue ein
afrikanische Kunstsammlung auf ich
gründe Unternehmen mein jüngste Kind ist
drei ich bin 70 Jahre alt ich habe vier
Kinder 13 und jünger
was sagt das also über mich aus ich
meine ich bin da draußen Dinge
viele Dinge die die Ungleichheit
aufrechterhalten Wirtschaftssysteme
Regierungspolitik ich würde sagen dass
auch die Psychologie eine Rolle spielt
die Art und Weise wie Menschen denken
die Dinge die sie schätzen die
Ungleichheit nimmt zu aber die Menschen
sind sich nicht bewusst was sie tun um
dazu beizutragen
[Musik]
die meisten der bewachten Wohnsiedlungen
liegen entweder auf einem Golfplatz oder
in der Nähe eines Golfplatzes einige der
Annehmlichkeiten sind wirklich toll
[Musik]
aber für manche Leute geht es mehr darum
hinter einem Tor zu leben ich lebe
hinter einem Tor und du lebst nicht
hinter einem Tor und sieh mal wie viel
besser es ist dass ich hinter dem Tor
lebe
wir haben dieses Haus nicht gekauft um
unsere Freunde auszuschließen die kein
Haus hinter dem Tor haben aber wir
hatten viele Freunde die wirklich
dachten das sei so wir hatten Freunde
die sagten nein wir werden euch nicht
besuchen kommen so in etwa ihr seid da
drüben hingezogen wir leben auf dieser
Seite
es ist wirklich traurig wirklich traurig
[Musik]
im allgemeinen bleiben alle ziemlich
unter sich
[Musik]
willst du die Bananen für deinen
Sandwich
wir wissen nicht über unsere Nachbarn
nichts ich habe noch einen Hamburger
gefunden
eine Sache die ein paar unserer Nachbarn
wirklich auf die Palme gebracht hat ist
dass wir keinen Gärtner angestellt haben
einmal kam dieser Nachbar heraus und
starrte mich an wer ich war sichtlich
schwanger beim laubhaken Start einfach
nur und schreit von der anderen
Straßenseite rüber
wissen sie nur arme Leute Haken ihr
eigenes Laub
wie aufgeregt bist du nimm das Jaguar
sei nett wie aufgeregt bist du das Haus
zu sehen ich bin sehr aufgeregt ich
glaube dass da viele junge Leute in der
Siedlung sind die so sind wie wir ich
werde eine ganz neue Gruppe junger Väter
kennenlernen die mit mir Fußball spielen
und Softporn und Tennis und ich habe das
Gefühl dass das die beste Gemeinschaft
ist die wir uns hätten wünschen können
sie hat einen großartigen schulbezeug
ich glaube wir haben wirklich großes
Glück gehabt
neulich mit jemandem gesprochen und er
meinte es ist ein Ort an dem es
Tennisplätze gibt einen Pool ein
bewachtes Tor eine Menge junger Leute
und er meinte wow das müssen die Reichen
und die großen sein ja das ist das ja
das ist also wie ein naja wie ein
ungeschliffen hat Diamant das ist der
beste Ort in westester das ist großartig
ja jeder orientiert sich bei der Wahl
seines Wohnorts an den Schulen wir
werden unsere Mädchen auf eine Schule in
arzlich schicken einem der besten
Schulbezirke des Landes und es wird eine
super Lebensqualität und ein großartiges
Umfeld sein indem wir tolle
Familientreffen werden
und ich glaube es wird lustig weil ich
dort viele Wall Street Leute treffen
werde
ich habe in diesem geschlossenen
Siedlungen Leute getroffen die einfach
nur sagen weißt du rich ich will nur
dass meine Kinder auf sichere Schulen
gehen ich möchte einfach nur dass meine
Immobilienwerte stabil bleiben ich will
die schönen Annehmlichkeiten des Lebens
private Parks private Radwege private
sehen sie sind sich über die Privilegien
die sie haben gar nicht so bewusst was
gucken wir uns zuerst an okay also wir
sind jetzt in
wir sind in boulderich das ist eine
große Gemeinde mit hunderten von Häusern
sie hat einen Partner der 24 Stunden am
Tag Wache schiebt so dass niemand hier
herkommen kann ohne dass man weiß wer es
ist
das heißt dass es hier keine
Kriminalität gibt das ist toll das gibt
mir ein sicheres Gefühl wenn ich
außerhalb der Stadt arbeite weil ich
weiß dass die Mädchen sicher sind ja
genau
schöne Autos hier
ich glaube das ist der perfekte Ort für
Sie
sobald man eine bestimmte Steuerklasse
erreicht hat wird erwartet dass man
einfach so weiter macht wie es der
Steuerklasse entspricht
Autos sind eine große Sache
most people Drive die meisten Leute
fahren einen Mercedes oder einen BMW
oder wenn Sie ein amerikanisches Auto
fahren ist es die neueste Version von
was auch immer
es ist nicht so dass wir uns entschieden
haben einen Hyundai von 1988 zu fahren
ich bin sehr glücklich darüber dass mein
Auto schon 200.000 Meilen geschafft hat
das heißt dass ich mich um etwas
gekümmert habe für das ich eine Menge
Geld hingelegt habe aber so wird das
hier nicht gemacht man kauft etwas
benutzt es etwa sechs Wochen lang und
dann wird man es los und kauft die
neueste Version von was auch immer das
it-ding gerade ist
[Musik]
die Menschen waren schon immer irgendwie
besessen davon etwas zu besetzen das
Auto das Fahren die Kleidung die sie
tragen so wie man auch sein Haus in
gutem Zustand verlassen will weil die
Leute einen danach beurteilen wie man
aussieht oder was man trägt
[Musik]
wenn man in dieser Branche mit
hochrangigen Führungskräften Sportlern
und Entertainern zusammenarbeitet
erwarten Sie einen bestimmten
Präsentationsstil
ich muss also in ihren Augen ein
bestimmtes Image aufrecht erhalten damit
sie mich respektieren und meine Meinung
schätzen
ich lasse mir also manchmal von meiner
Frau helfen wenn es um Stil geht
Markennamen und dergleichen sie scheint
sehr gut darin zu sein mich für den
Erfolg zu gleiten
und ich glaube fest daran dass man sich
wenn man sich jeden Tag gut kleidet
stärker und erfolgreicher fühlt
man kann sich im Grunde genommen so
anziehen dass man Erfolg hat ich habe
gesehen wie Menschen aus einer
Depression kam quasi weil sie gut
aussehen
fühl dich wie ein erfolgreicher Typ und
du bist ein erfolgreicher Typ
[Musik]
das primäre Transportmittel hier in der
Siedlung ist der Golfwagen
jeder kann mit seinem Golfwagen angeben
es gibt Golfwagen mit geländerädern es
gibt Golfwagen mit besonderer Ausrüstung
es gibt Sets die man vorne aufstecken
kann um das golfauto wie einen Mercedes
aussehen zu lassen die Leute stecken 10
20.000 Dollar in ein golfauto
Amerikaner sind vernünftig und sagen
nicht ich ziehe in eine bewachte
Siedlung um vor den schwarzen zu fliehen
die meisten Leute denken nicht so sie
sagen sich einfach ich ziehe wegen der
Sicherheit wegen der höheren
Immobilienwerte hier hin
das hat nichts mit Rasse zu tun es gibt
also eine Kluft so wird eine
Gemeinschaft isoliert diejenigen die da
scheinbar nicht reinpassen werden nicht
akzeptiert Menschen die nicht Golf
spielen Menschen die nicht in eine
bestimmte Kirche gehen diese Art von
Menschen fühlen sich oft ausgeschlossen
nein wir gehen nicht nein hey halt dich
fest
danke
ich finde das toll dass du so gut hörst
when als wir hierher gekommen sind haben
wir gesehen dass am Ende der Straße
einen Park ist
alle zusammen spielen und alle hätten
eine schöne Zeit miteinander aber so ist
das hier leider nicht
okay rauf auf den Bordstein
[Musik]
na dann mal los
wir sehen zumindest ethnisch aus wie die
große Mehrheit unserer Nachbarschaft und
ich habe mich immer noch nicht damit
abgefunden dass meine Kinder als die
anderen wahrgenommen werden
nicht zu nah an die schaukeln
ich will nicht dass du einen Schlag an
den Kopf bekommst
ich habe ganz normal aussehende
blondhaarige blauäugige nette Kinder und
dieses Mädchen ist auf dem Spielplatz
schreien vom Max weggerannt
einfach weggerannt und sie hat ihn immer
wieder angeschrien und wie schrecklich
er sei und ihre Mutter sagte ja das ist
okay Schatz ich weiß
irgendwas stimmt hier nicht wenn mein
völlig normales Kind auf dem Spielplatz
keine Freunde findet
[Musik]
ich habe meinen Mann mehr als einmal
weinend angerufen
[Musik]
ich kann mit meinem Kind nicht in den
Park gehen
[Musik]
New York boomt der Konsum ist wieder in
Mode die luxusautohändler können sich
kaum noch an eine solche Zeit zurück
erinnern
die glauben sie das ein einzelner zu
viel Geld verdienen kann was meinen Sie
dass wir das Einkommen begrenzen sollten
nicht wirklich nein warum wozu
was wir wissen ist dass die Menschen an
der Spitze der einkommensleiter alle
Einkommens zu Wechsel der letzten 30
Jahre erhalten haben die Menschen in der
Mitte der Einkommensverteilung haben
ihre Ersparnisse aufgebraucht sie haben
viel mehr Schulden angehäuft man muss
jede nur erdenkliche Spanne ausschöpfen
um seinen Platz in der Schlange zu
halten
sie können sich bis zu 31 Tage lang bis
zu 1.000 Pfund leihen das ist perfekt um
ihren kurzfristigen Cashflow zu managen
die heute veröffentlichen Zahl der
Regierung zeigen dass eine Rekordzahl
von Menschen in solvent ist wenn Sie die
Einkommenssteuer nicht innerhalb von
sieben Tagen zahlen wird ein
inkasso-team Kontakt mit Ihnen aufnehmen
und sie zu Hause aufsuchen der Brief
wurde am ersten geschrieben heute ist
der 9 und was sagen die wann wollen die
kommen innerhalb von 7 Tagen
du solltest Sie anrufen
was so viel musst du zahlen
die Rechnung liegt bei dreieinhalb 4000
Pfund aber ich brauche es für Sachen sie
wissen schon wenn die Kinder neue Jacken
brauchen neue Schuhe ich habe kein Geld
mehr ich muss es ja irgendwo herbekommen
alles ist einfach so viel teurer
geworden und Lucina will einen Computer
und man hat immer das Gefühl dass man
das dann auch tun muss weil ihre Freunde
haben auch einen und wenn sie keinen
bekommt ist sie Außenseiterin
man muss Abstriche machen manchmal ruft
die Schule an sie haben das Essensgeld
nicht bezahlt das kommt ziemlich oft vor
[Musik]
win from viele Menschen haben sich von
einem ziemlich einfachen finanziellen
Leben vor 1980 zu einem Punkt entwickelt
an dem sie völlig in Rechnungen
versinken sie sind alle verschuldet für
uns sind Schulden etwas ich brauche
einen Kredit um zur Schule zu gehen oder
um ein Haus zu kaufen aber für die Wall
Street ist es nur ein Produkt dass sie
kaufen und verkaufen und verpacken
können es ist also nur eine weitere
Möglichkeit für Sie so viel Profit zu
machen wie sie wollen sie behandeln es
wie ein Spiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt einige Schulden bei
verschiedenen Firmen aber das einzige
was ich tun kann ist dass sie sich in
der Schlange anstellen und warten ich
muss für zwei Wochen zahlen die Hälfte
der Miete und die Säumnisgebühr und all
das es ist das reinste jonglieren ich
kann am Dienstag für den Cheeseburger
zahlen den wir heute essen
ja ja so ist es nunmal
es war einmal ein Kerl seine Kumpels
nannten ihn Joe und der fand heraus wir
haben zu viele Schulden
wir brauchen einen Kredit der bis zum
Zahltag reicht also ginge auf Donnerstag
ist schnell und bequem du musst nur 18
Jahre alt sein und einen festen
Arbeitsplatz haben und du bekommst
direkt eine Sofortzahlung Donnerstag
bewerben Sie sich unterhalten sie noch
am selben Tag Bargeld
eines der Dinge über die ich heute
sprechen will ist wie wir ein sichereres
Amerika schaffen können indem wir es
schaffen das fünfeinhalb Millionen
Angehöriger von Minderheiten ein Haus
kaufen
wir wollen nicht dass irgendetwas
Kleingedrucktes die Menschen daran
hindert ein eigenes Haus zu besitzen als
die Wall Street herausfand dass sie
diese hypothekenprodukte entwickeln
konnte hieß es wow das ist das Geschäft
des Jahrhunderts wir müssen mehr davon
machen
ein Haus ist immer das große Ding das
ist die Art und Weise wie die Wirtschaft
aufgebaut ist
ein Haus Immobilienwerte steigen
normalerweise es ist also ein wichtiger
Bestandteil deines Ruhestands
und wenn du dein Haus verlierst kannst
du in eine Lage geraten in der du nicht
mehr in den Ruhestand gehen kannst
sondern weiterarbeiten musst
wenn man ein Haus kauft geht man mit
hunderttausenden von Dollar eine Wetter
ein dass dieses Haus einen Wert behält
und das alles gut geht
[Musik]
Häuser die drastisch hinter dem Trend
zurück bleiben sind wirklich schwer zu
verkaufen
und wenn sie dann doch verkauft werden
dann für weniger Geld ich glaube es wäre
ein größerer Druck wenn wir heute aktiv
versuchen würden unser Haus zu verkaufen
wir versuchen einfach Schritt zu halten
und dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht so
weit zurückfallen
ich bin die Eigentümerin von ranchamaria
Horns und release date es ist mir ein
Vergnügen schön dass sie es geschafft
haben der Preis für dieses Haus beträgt
429.900 Dollar und es steht auf einem
Grundstück von einem Viertel Hektar
und sie haben so viele Upgrades gemacht
es ist im Grunde ein brandneues Haus
ursprünglich wurde es 1981 gebaut was
mir daran gefällt achtung die Stufen sie
haben überall neues Laminat verlegt die
Fenster haben sie nicht erneuert die
sind noch einfach verglast nur in diesem
Raum sind sie doppelt verglast
aber sie haben eine komplett neue
Heizung und Klimaanlage eingebaut die
12.000 Dollar gekostet hat jetzt muss
ich Ihnen zeigen wie fantastisch diese
Schränke sind es sind ausziehschränke
und sie schließen sich ganz von selbst
hier ist ein Gasanschluss der hier hat
Propangas das ist eine Kupferleitung
interessant
und alle Häuser haben einen anderen
Charakter und einen anderen Stil
besonders dieses hier das ist ein
schönes Haus ein schöner Eingang ja es
hat einfach einen schönen Stil
das ist wirklich eine der besten Straßen
in dieser Gegend sie ist absolut ruhig
man sieht eigentlich niemanden vorbei
gehen außer die Leute die hier wohnen
und die teuersten Häuser in der
Nachbarschaft liegen hier die Straße
runter und am See
kommen Sie rein mal sehen was sie davon
halten
das erste Haus hat mit Abstand die
höchste Quadratmeterzahl ja ich habe
nicht das Gefühl dass sie viel dafür
bekommen ja mit großem Abstand aber ich
glaube zumindest wenn man das mit
unserem Haus vergleicht ist noch alles
gut wenn wir in eine Situation kommen
sollten wo wir unser Haus verkaufen
müssen dann ginge es immer noch
einigermaßen gut ja
meistens ist mein erster Patient um 11
Uhr da das heißt ich stehe so gegen 8
auf sehe meine Sportsachen an und laufe
eine Runde
ich laufe etwa 45 Minuten bis eine
Stunde
ich liebe es draußen zu laufen
eigentlich muss mich ziemlich anstrengen
aber es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit
als mich anzustrengen wissen sie man
steht mit dem Rücken zur Wand wenn man
eine Hypothek abbezahlen muss
er wurde gerade am Rücken operiert und
er hat buchstäblich am nächsten Tag
gearbeitet wurde am Mittwoch operiert
hat am Donnerstag und Freitag gearbeitet
und ist am Montag ins Büro gegangen er
hatte einen Krankheitstag konnte nicht
ins Büro gehen und Geld verdienen es ist
also wichtig dass er gesund bleibt für
sich selbst für unsere Familie und für
seine Kunden
die Regierung hatte Daten gesammelt die
zeigten dass es diese riesigen
Klassenunterschiede in der
Lebenserwartung gab und und die Leute
glauben den Daten nicht wirklich selbst
Leute die in wichtigen Positionen im
Gesundheitswesen arbeiteten wussten
nicht ob die Sterberaten oben oder unten
am höchsten waren
von Kokain zu Ketamin zu
kapitalistischen Prinzipien ich habe
versucht mein Lächeln wieder auf sein
Gesicht zu zaubern aber es ist mir nicht
gelungen also verabschiede ich mich
tränenreich von all meinen Prinzipien
bis auf eins fange an mich mit dem Flow
zu unterhalten der mich auf diesen
rutschigen Weg geführt hat ich war nicht
immer so ich schätze es begann an dem
Tag an dem sie den Sack öffnet und sie
wegflog und mich hier am Boden liegen
zurück liest während ich mich an dem
größten Schmerz schmückte mein größtes
Ziel im Leben ist es einen Tag zu
überstehen
meine Mama war 36 als sie starb wenn ich
so weiter trinke bin ich das auch
stell dir mal vor mit 36 zu sterben
verdammt noch mal
all die Dinge die ich tun muss um zu
versuchen mein Leben zu verlängern das
bereits verkürzt ist weil ich am geboren
wurde wenn ich es bis 70 schaffe kann
ich mich glücklich schätzen aber auch
nur wenn ich jeden Tag Salat esse
jetzt weiß man natürlich aufgrund einer
wachsenden Zahl von Untersuchungen das
Arbeitslosigkeit und Armut
gesundheitliche Folgen haben
statt der früheren Vorstellung dass es
der Stress des Geschäftsmannes ist der
zu den schlimmsten gesundheitlichen
Problemen führt
[Musik]
es gibt eine Menge Gesundheitsprobleme
die reichen von Bluthochdruck über AIDS
bis hin zu hepatitis alle möglichen
Krankheiten
jeder Tag über der Erde ist ein guter
Tag das ist das was mir gesagt wurde das
ist das was ich weiß
der Vater meiner Tochter ist letztes
Jahr gestorben
das hat mich ziemlich umgehauen
plötzlich war ich alleinerziehende
Mutter
er starb an Leberkrebs
ja es war wirklich traurig
aber es ist alles okay ich weiß dass er
jetzt an einem besseren Ort ist er hat
eine Weile gelitten verdammt viel
vermissen sie ihn ja das tue ich
wir haben 14 Jahre zusammen gelebt eine
lange Zeit
ja
in
Glasgow haben Männer die in der ernsten
Gegend leben eine Lebenserwartung von 54
Jahren
in Indien leben drei Viertel der
Bevölkerung von zwei Dollar pro Tag oder
weniger niemand in Glasgow lebt von zwei
Dollar pro Tag oder weniger und dennoch
haben Männer im ernsten Teil Glasgows
eine Lebenserwartung die acht Jahre
unter dem indischen Durchschnitt liegt
und ich dachte aha das ist das genau
hat tiefgreifende Folgen
von Selbstmord gewaltsamen Todesfällen
Alkohol und Herzkrankheiten
niederschlagen hatte sie
draußen hatte ich meine erste Sauferei
es war Freitagabend wir kamen hier
runter und wir hatten eine Flasche old
Westminster dabei
eine es war witzig am Ende hatte ich
meine Zähne voller Sand und ich war
benebelt vom Alkohol
aber ich weiß noch wie ich dachte das
ist ekelhaft warum sollte jemand sowas
tun wollen
aber ich sage ich wünschte ich könnte
süchtig danach werden ins Fitnessstudio
zu gehen
weißt du machen was man sagt
aber ich brauche keine Bananen ich
sollte lieber mit dem Alkohol aufhören
der Alkohol gab mir das was ich für
Selbstvertrauen hielt er lässt einen
glauben dass man etwas wert ist
wie ein Schmerzmittel
[Musik]
jeder versucht auf seine eigene Weise zu
entkommen sie versuchen zu flüchten
indem sie irgendwelche Sachen tun
Marihuana und sowas
oder Menschen mittleren Alters trinken
wahrscheinlich oder tun etwas um zu
entkommen
älteren Leuten ist es vielleicht egal
weil sie alt sind sie müssen sich nicht
mehr mit sowas auseinandersetzen
aber jeder versucht vor irgendwas zu
fliehen
was tun Sie um zu fliehen
ich nehme mein Bier meine Zigaretten ab
und zu ein kleines Bier und das war's
dann auch schon ich schaue mir einen
guten Film an und gehe ins Bett
haben sie ein Lieblingsessen nein also
eigentlich Eiscreme ich mag Eiscreme
manchmal setze ich mich mit einem ganzen
Becher davon hin und esse bis ich nicht
mehr kann bis ich voll bin
ich finde man sieht gut aus wenn man ein
bisschen Fleisch auf den Knochen hat
das heißt dass man zu Hause gut ist
[Musik]
ich bin die ganze Zeit sehr nervös und
die Nervosität ist einfach sogar die
Kunden sagen schon nicht lächle nicht
mehr gestern hat mir zum Beispiel ein
Mann gesagt sie sehen aus als müssten
sie sich beruhigen und ich sage ich kann
nicht und er meint sie werden einen
Herzinfarkt bekommen und ich sage ich
weiß
[Musik]
früher habe ich gearbeitet und bin dann
joggen gegangen ins Fitnessstudio und so
weiter und wo bin ich dann gelandet
jetzt gehe ich lieber nach Hause und
setze mich hin und esse etwas
[Musik]
es ist wirklich so man sagt sich Mann
war das wieder hart weil wir so knapp
bei Kasse sind ich werde mich jetzt
einfach in die Ecke setzen und ein paar
Chips essen bis ich wieder runterkomme
aber das ist ja auch nicht der richtige
Weg
[Musik]
wenn man einen Wirtschaftskurs belegt
lernt man das Märkte auf rationalen
Entscheidungen informierter Verbraucher
beruhen
angenommen sie schalten den Fernseher
ein und sehen sich die Werbung an ich
meine aber versuchen sie informierte
Verbraucher zu schaffen die rationale
Entscheidungen treffen
ganz im Gegenteil sie versuchen
uniformierte Verbraucher zu schaffen die
irrational handeln und das ist eine
riesige Industrie eine der größten
Industrien überhaupt
[Applaus]
die Leute hier sind ziemlich groß ja
gesund
[Musik]
Mama bist du müde ja bin ich
als ich meine Tochter bekommen habe
hatte ich eine Herzinsuffizienz ich bin
eigentlich buchstäblich gestorben
es hat zwei Wochen gedauert bis ich aus
dem Koma erwacht bin ich habe einfach
Glück dass mein Herz noch schlägt biegen
noch so lange um zu tun was noch zu tun
ist aber dadurch wird es nur noch
schwächer
wann wurde Bluthochdruck bei ihnen
festgestellt im Jahr 2004
seid ruhig
seid und
Macht zu
mach alle Türen zu
alles muss zu sein und alle müssen sich
hinsetzen und still sein
[Musik]
es beruhigt mich einfach zu wissen dass
nachts jemand auf uns alle aufpasst wenn
ich mit meinen Kindern alleine zu Hause
bin
[Musik]
Nachricht gespeichert nächste Nachricht
hey bob sagt wir lieben Dich Daddy ich
hab
dich lieb sag gute Nacht gute Nacht
träum schön wie lieb habt ihr Papa sehr
lieb ich liebe dich
ich würde ihn gerne öfter sehen ich sage
immer ich wünschte ich hätte einen
Ehemann der einen Nein zu five-job hat
dann könnten wir abends zusammen nach
Hause kommen und uns gemeinsam um die
Kinder kümmern aber ich weiß dass das
nicht geht und ich weiß dass er uns
einen Lebensstil ermöglicht den wir ohne
seine harte Arbeit nicht haben könnten
wir wissen das finanzielle Not einer der
Hauptfaktoren ist der Menschen zu
eheberatern treibt in den Gebieten in
denen die Ungleichheit am stärksten
zugenommen hat wir haben einen enormen
Anstieg der Scheidungsraten die Menschen
in der Mitte versuchen über die Runden
zu kommen und erleben dabei eine enorme
zusätzliche Belastungen in ihrem Leben
Zeit ins Bett zu gehen kleines Kälbchen
kleines Kälbchen was ist heute passiert
dass dich zum Lachen gebracht hat
okay gibt Mami einen Kuss nach einer
Woche bin ich erschöpft ich arbeite den
ganzen Tag und dann komme ich nach Hause
und habe zwei Kinder die ich füttern und
baden und Dinge nicht vorlesen muss um
all die Stunden wieder gut zu machen wie
ich tagsüber nicht zu Hause war
ich habe euch lieb
gute Nacht
[Musik]
es ist furchtbar ich habe enorme
Schuldgefühle weil ich die Mädchen nicht
sehen und ins Bett bringen kann und es
ist frustrierend wenn die Mädchen nähern
sie gewöhnt sind als an mich hallo
ich bin so fertig von heute alles gut
und wie geht's dir mir geht's gut
dieses Blatt hier heißt Gotcha für alle
kriminellen in der Gegend Seite für
Seite steht da wer verhaftet worden ist
und was er getan hat
manchmal gucke ich hier rein um zu sehen
ob meine Söhne Unsinn gemacht haben
während ich bei der Arbeit war
das kommt von den Leuten die gestresst
sind weil die Wirtschaft hier im Arsch
ist
und deshalb haben wir so eine Situation
Leute die Straftaten begehen Überfälle
weil sie frustriert sind keinen Job
finden sie brechen irgendwo ein und
versuchen in die Häuser anderer Leute zu
kommen
reine Wut gegen andere einer mit dem
anderen
sie suchen sich einfach irgendwas um den
Frust rauszulassen sie haben ja sonst
nicht viel zu tun
Psychologen und Soziologen die mit
Gewalttätern Arbeiten sagen immer wieder
dass mangelnder Respekt der Auslöser für
Gewalttaten und Aggressionen ist alles
was den Menschen bleibt ist die
Bewahrung ihre Selbstachtung und wenn
die in irgendeiner Weise bedroht ist
kommt es zu gewalttätigen und
aggressiven Reaktionen
laut Polizei starben zwei Teenager und
ein 15-jähriges Mädchen bei einer
Schießerei auf einer Geburtstagsfeier in
einem privaten Club das ist nicht
ungewöhnlich in den letzten Jahren sind
in dieser kleinen Stadt viele Menschen
getötet worden
Highschool Schüler die sich gegenseitig
umbringen man weiß nie wann man
ausgeraubt wird und
ich würde gerne zu Fuß zur Arbeit gehen
oder mit dem Fahrrad weil es nur etwa
zwei Meilen die Straße runter ist weil
aber ich habe zu viel Angst mit dem
Fahrrad zu fahren oder um Mitternacht
nach Hause zu laufen ich habe immer
Angst davor durch den Park zu laufen
immer jetzt wo die Hälfte der Lichter
aus ist es ein sehr gefährlicher Ort
wir hatten letztes Jahr 116 Morde
dreimal so viele wie in dieser Kirche
sitzen
Polizei und Gemeinde versuchen eine
Epidemie von Gewaltverbrechen zu
bekämpfen die zum großen Teil auf Drogen
zurückzuführen ist
Straßenfeger Schrotflinte 12 Kaliber 12
Schuss in diesem Trommelmagazin kein
Visier weil es nicht dafür ausgelegt ist
ein Visier zu brauchen
[Musik]
ich habe die Nase voll von diesem
Commonwealth ich bin gestresst diese
Stadt ist einfach so kaputt guckt euch
das doch an guck mich an
[Musik]
ich vertraue niemandem mehr
ich halte diese Tür geschlossen wenn es
hier dunkel wird bin ich drin
es ist mir egal was da draußen ist mir
geht's gut so
dieser Krieg gegen das Verbrechen wird
auf allen Ebenen geführt diejenigen die
sich leisten können gehen dem aus dem
weg ziehen sich in bewachte Siedlungen
zurück von wo aus Sie den neuen
republikanischen Kampf um das Überleben
der Amerikaner beobachten können
[Musik]
ja wir sind hier um die grows zu
besuchen gehe
so hier ist es hatten Sie bisher einen
schönen Abend ja bisher war der Tag ganz
schön so alles klar danke schön
mein Nachbar hat ihn gesehen und uns
angerufen
anscheinend wurde eines seiner Hühner
zerfleischt und ein anderes wurde
herausgerissen und herumgejagt ich
konnte die Sache mit dem schlichten und
ihn beruhigen
ihr wurde ein Coyote gesichtet haben sie
dir irgendwelche Infos darüber gegeben
nicht viel nur dass er auf der Nordseite
über die Straße gelaufen ist oder sich
an als wäre es ein großes Tier gewesen
ja hört sich an
er hängt jetzt schon ein paar Monate
hier rum oder ich glaube schon
[Musik]
und das Pumpenhaus jemand hat da oben
ein paar Steine durch die Fenster
geworfen
und das dieser andere streunende der
Hund von dem wir gesprochen hatten
das müssen wir erledigen sieht ja so aus
als ob alles ordentlich auf den Karten
vermerkt ist
ich hole mir jetzt deine Tasse Kaffee du
kannst ja ein bisschen die Füße
vertreten und dann machen wir weiter
klingt nach einem Plan ich habe gerade
einen frischen für dich gemacht
Gewaltverbrechen und die Angst die sie
hervorrufen lähmen unsere Gesellschaft
schränken die persönliche Freiheit ein
und lösen unsere Verbindung auf
denen die wiederholt Gewaltverbrechen
begehen sollte gesagt werden wenn du ein
drittes Gewaltverbrechen begehst wirst
du weggesperrt und zwar für immer wer
dreimal zuschlägt ist raus
ich bin mit einem Gramm Rauschgift
erwischt worden 1,5 Gramm okay ich würde
nie jemandem weh tun außer mir selbst
ich hätte es nicht verkauft ich habe es
auch nicht an Kinder weitergegeben oder
sowas und dann stand ich vor Gericht
aber sie haben nicht mal versucht mir
zuzuhören wir haben das Story strikes
Gesetz gegen mich angewandt und nicht zu
25 Jahren Haft verurteilt ich war in den
letzten 17 Jahren in einer Kiste die nur
ein bisschen größer war als diese und
eingesperrt zu sein und so behandelt zu
werden wie ich hier behandelt wurde
da gibt es keine lebenden Mann der nicht
genauso fühlen würde wie ich jetzt sie
haben Hass in mir geschaffen
ja ich bin im Zuchthaus
aber weißt du was
ich bin noch nie mit etwas erwischt
worden
ich muss mich vor den Frauen und den
Beamten ausziehen mich bücken und ihn
mein Arschloch zeigen
demütigt es ist mehr als das
ich hatte alle alle in meinem Mund
die haben sie mir in der Robertson
Einheit rausgeschlagen ich wurde fast zu
Tode geprügelt
sie haben mir acht Rippen gebrochen sie
haben mir die Arme ausgekugelt die Beine
sie haben mir den Kiefer gebrochen der
hat mir die Zahnreihe herausgeschlagen
sie haben mir das augenbein gebrochen
die Nase aber wissen Sie was als mir
drei Tage später das erste Mal der Kopf
abgerissen wurde war das nicht mehr so
weh
und dann wurde ich zu einem Monster
ich hasse Menschen
und weißt du wie traurig das ist das zu
sagen
ich bin hier so schlecht verhandelt
worden das ja ich könnte tatsächlich ich
könnte einen Mann töten ja das könnte
ich wirklich wirklich
das ist traurig weil ich besser erzogen
wurde als das
und was werde ich jetzt tun wenn ich
rauskomme was soll ich tun mir einen Job
bei McDonald's besorgen ich werde 54
Jahre alt sein ich kann mit 26 Jahren
hierher
ich war auf dem College und wurde da
weggeholt
und was soll ich jetzt tun
denn was du warst bevor Du uns Gefängnis
kamst ist nicht das was du sein wirst
wenn du und lassen wirst
[Musik]
das ist kein Land das mit der Sprache
der Freiheit begonnen hat und doch haben
wir mehr Häftlinge pro Kopf als
irgendein anderes Land auf der Welt
[Musik]
besteht kein Zweifel daran dass es viel
unwahrscheinlicher ist inaktiv zu werden
wenn man reich ist selbst wenn man etwas
Schreckliches getan hat
[Musik]
wir haben hier 24 massive Silber und 2,2
Karat Diamanten
das ist das reichste Jahr der Geschichte
der Menschheit
die Reichen werden immer reicher der
Beweis ist auf unserer Liste und das
sind Macher das sind keine Plutokraten
das sind Macher die etwas bewirken und
wenn es ihnen gut geht geht es uns allen
gut
es gibt eine Religion die besagt das
jeder davon profitieren wird das hat
fast nichts mit der realen Welt zu tun
sie versagt in der echten Welt komplett
the ROM versagen ist das falsche Wort es
ist kein Versagen für den Bruchteil von
einem Prozent der Bevölkerung der
Reichtum anhäuft mehr als Sie es sich
vorstellen können der Einfluss des
Geldes auf die Politik hat in den
letzten Jahrzehnten dramatisch
zugenommen die Leute an der Spitze haben
mehr Geld sie spenden den Politikern
immer mehr Geld und fordern im Gegenzug
niedrigere Steuersätze für sich selbst
und weniger strenge Vorschriften für
ihre Unternehmen
in einer kleinen Stadt in arken
Zaubernden einzelhandelsun hat Walmart
seit 1962 einen langen Weg zurückgelegt
niemand außer vielleicht Sam der seine
ursprüngliche Idee nie aus den Augen
verloren hat hätte das bemerkenswerte
Wachstum des Unternehmens vorhersagen
können
ist ein interessanter Fall denn Walmart
hat eine große Anzahl von
erdmilliardären hervorgebracht sie sind
in den Gemeinden in denen sie leben
zweifellos hoch angesehen und zweifellos
tun sie auch respektable Dinge sie
finanzieren Museen und Spenden Geld für
Krankenhäuser und sowas und dennoch in
vielen Gemeinden bekommt die Leute die
bei Walmart arbeiten zwar einen Lohn
aber gleichzeitig auch
Lebensmittelmarken im Grunde zahlt also
die Öffentlichkeit für die Arbeit von
Walmart
im Geschäftsjahr 2012 hatte Walmart
einen Bruttoumsatz von rund 446
Milliarden und der Nettogewinn lag bei
16,7 also fast 17 Milliarden Dollar ich
habe kein Problem damit wenn ein
Unternehmen gewinnen macht wie ich schon
sagte ich hatte mein eigenes Unternehmen
aber wenn man auf Kosten der Menschen
die die Arbeit tun Gewinn macht und die
dann von Lebensmittelmarken leben dann
ist es eine moralische Frage wenn man
die Entscheidung trifft okay wir kürzen
die Arbeitsstunden damit wir mehr Gewinn
machen denn sie wissen was sie tun
wir haben herausgefunden dass
wohlhabendere Menschen das verfolgen
ihre eigenen Interessen im Gegensatz zu
kollektiven Interessen er als moralisch
und gut empfinden wir beobachten sogar
eine Moralisierung der Gier diese geist
ist geil Mentalität
diese Kultur stellt wirklich die
psychopathischen Denker heraus Menschen
die keine Empathie haben denn wenn man
einmal erfolgreich ethische Erweckungen
ausgeklammert hat ist man unglaublich
effizient ich denke es ist nichts falsch
daran es bequem haben zu wollen ich weiß
nicht mal ob es falsch ist reich sein zu
wollen aber das Bestreben der Wall
Street ist es you money zu haben
und you many heißt das ist eine so
große Menge an Geld das man zum Telefon
greifen und you sagen kann zu wem
man will ohne irgendwelche Konsequenzen
eine der notwendigen Illusionen für die
Allgemeinheit ist dass wir in einer
kapitalistischen Wirtschaft leben
aber die reichen glauben das nicht eine
Minute lang sie bestehen auf einen
mächtigen Staat der sie vor der
Marktdisziplin schützt wenn Goldman
Sachs also ein riskantes Geschäft macht
sind sie im Grunde genommen geschützt
wenn die Firma zusammenbricht können Sie
mit der Mütze in der Hand zu Mutterstadt
rennen und sich aus der Patsche helfen
lassen
guten Morgen das ist ein entscheidender
Moment für Amerikas Wirtschaft Probleme
die auf den Kreditmärkten entstanden
sind und sich zuerst den Bereich der
subprime Hypotheken zeigten haben sich
auf unser gesamtes Finanzsystem
ausgeweitet
es war eine düstere Woche an der Wall
Street an den letzten fünf Handelstagen
hat der Dow Jones allein 1.400 Punkte
verloren die Investoren sind sich einig
dass dies eine entscheidende Woche ist
um zu sehen ob die Regierung eingreifen
und die Wirtschaft heilen kann oder
nicht ich bin ein starker verfächter des
freien Unternehmertums unter normalen
Umständen bin ich der Meinung des
Unternehmen die schlechte Entscheidungen
treffen die Möglichkeit haben sollten
ihr Geschäft aufzugeben aber das sind
keine normalen Umstände
wissen sie der Präsident hat immer
wieder gesagt dass es das Geld des
Volkes ist damit hat er recht es ist das
Geld des Volkes aber jetzt sind es die
Schulden des Volkes
das ist ein Schmerz der Milch für den
Rest meines Lebens begleiten wird aber
sie dürfen 480 Millionen behalten ich
habe eine ganz einfache Frage an Sie ist
das fair
das Spektakel dieser Banker die in hohem
Maße dazu beigetragen haben die
westlichen Volkswirtschaften in die Knie
zu zwingen und sich trotzdem weiter
bezahlen so viel Geld wie sich die
meisten nicht einmal vorstellen können
und Sie glauben wirklich dass sie es
wert sind manchmal treffe ich sie in der
Öffentlichkeit und sie sagen Max wann
begreifst du endlich dass der
Kapitalismus so funktioniert ich sage
dann das ist nicht wie der Kapitalismus
funktioniert so geht der Kapitalismus
hoffnungslos und katastrophal schief
[Musik]
ich kann am besten für die Wall Street
Gemeinde sprechen weil ich ihr gegenüber
sitze
wissen Sie ich sehe dass die Menschen an
der Wall Street heute härter arbeiten
als je zuvor
ohne zu wissen ob sie jemals aufsteigen
können und waren dieses Rennen für sie
endet
[Musik]
ist ein klinischer Psychologe und
wahrscheinlich ist er vor allem dafür
bekannt dass er Menschen hilft mit
Unsicherheit umzugehen und in Zeiten der
Ungewissheit optimale Motivation und
Leistung aufrecht zu erhalten
[Applaus]
ich habe es mir zur Aufgabe gemacht den
Menschen in dieser schwierigen Zeit zu
helfen denn in meiner Praxis als
Psychologe habe ich das Gefühl dass
meine Klienten bei mir nach Antworten
suchen meine Dissertation ist die erste
Studie die in den Vereinigten Staaten in
den letzten 50 Jahren durchgeführt wurde
sie trug den Titel die Unfälle der Wall
Street eine Begutachtung der Verletzten
und meine Ergebnisse zeigten im Grunde
dass wir uns derzeit in einer
anschlusskrise befinden
[Musik]
wir sollten nicht dehnen aus der Patsche
helfen die die leichtsinnige
Entscheidung getroffen haben ein Haus
kaufen von dem sie wussten dass sie es
sich niemals leisten können
dieses Wort hörte man oft die gierigen
Hausbesitzer hier geht es umarme Leute
die mit ihrer zweiten Hypothek einen
Fernseher gekauft haben und es sei ihre
Schuld und sie seien gierig gewesen das
ist die Mentalität gibt dem Opfer die
Schuld
[Musik]
igung ich habe immer wieder meine
Kreditkarten benutzt um zu leben und
dann war ich mit den ersten Karten am
Limit ich bin am Ende und ich werde
umziehen
ich muss sehr bald umziehen in den
nächsten paar Wochen
es gibt eine Menge Daten die darauf
hindeuten dass die soziale Mobilität auf
einem historischen Tiefstand ist die
Menschen erreichen trotz harter Arbeit
nicht in amerikanischen Traum
der Wohlstand erreicht oft sind es
diejenigen die von vornherein in den
Wohlstand hineingeboren wurden
[Musik]
ich habe das Gefühl dass ich damit
gesegnet bin alles zu haben was ich
brauche ich könnte nicht glücklicher
sein ich könnte mir nicht mehr wünschen
[Musik]
mit 15 verließ ich big Stone Cat
Virginia und träumte quer durch den
ganzen Kontinent nach Südkalifornien
und ich hatte einen guten Job
ich war jung heterosexuell das Leben war
schön
ich dachte daran nach Hollywood zu gehen
und der nächste Tom Cruise oder sowas zu
werden
aber dann ist das anders gekommen
Mama meine Mutter hatte eine Herz- und
Lungeninfektion und sie starb im Jahr 89
es hat mich erdrückt
ich bin in einer Art Spirale geraten die
falschen Dinge getan um über die Runden
zu kommen
und das führte mich auf einen langen Weg
den ich nicht gehen wollte aber ich tat
es ich hing mit den falschen Leuten rum
Tat die falschen Dinge
versuchte Geld zu verdienen und
versuchte einfach zu überleben
ich ging für ein Jahr ins Gefängnis kam
wieder raus und konnte immer noch nicht
klar denken und dann habe ich Kinder
bekommen so dieser Zeit konnte ich sie
nicht bei mir haben weil ich so kaputt
war
aber nach meiner Herzinsuffizienz bin
ich aufgewacht
es war ein sehr groß den ich brauchte
ein dringend notwendiger weg und ich
habe es geschafft
seitdem geht es mit mir bergauf
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir glauben einfach nicht dass die
Regelschule ein guter Ort für Kinder ist
die auch nur ein bisschen über der Kurve
sind
also wahrscheinlich Homeschooling
wenn sie nicht auf den richtigen Weg
bleiben die Meilensteine nicht erreichen
die Ziele die sie erreichen sollen dann
wird sich das langfristig darauf
auswirken welches Ergebnis sie erzählen
keine Herausforderung ist dringlicher
keine Debatte ist wichtiger
wir können uns entweder mit einem Land
abfinden in dem es einer schrumpfenden
Zahl von Menschen wirklich gut geht
während eine wachsende Zahl von
Amerikanern kaum über die Runden kommt
oder wir können eine Wirtschaft
wiederherstellen in der jeder eine faire
Chance bekommt jeder seinen fairen
Beitrag leistet und jeder nach den
gleichen Regeln spielt
[Applaus]
die Ungleichheit ist nicht auf schlechte
Äpfel zurückzuführen sondern das Fass
ist schlecht
sind die Institutionen die das
Vorankommen über alles andere stellen
dass es in Ordnung ist das Gesetz zu
brechen wenn das heißt dass man dadurch
mehr Profit für das Unternehmen macht
ohne darauf zu achten was die
Konsequenzen für das System als Ganzes
sind
das Gefühl dass es da draußen einen
Mechanismus gibt gegen den man überhaupt
nichts tun kann das ist einfach nicht
wahr wenn Sie das ändern wollen können
Sie es ändern
[Musik]
mein Name ist Lea Taylor und ich bin
heute hier um meine Stimme zu erheben
für meine Kollegen und alle die in der
Fast Food Industrie zu kämpfen haben
was würden sie dem Chef von Airlines für
den sie arbeiten gerne sagen
ich gebe nicht
einem Unternehmen die Schuld
die Menschen im Stich gelassen werden
solange die Regierung die Bedeutung der
häuslichen Pflege in diesem Land nicht
anerkennt diese Probleme sind tief im
System verwurzelt und es ist das System
dass sich ändern muss
mein Name ist Janet Sparks und ich bin
Walmart Mitarbeiterin im Laden Nummer
11.02 wenn ich daran denke dass unser
Geschäftsführer letztes Jahr über 20
Millionen Dollar verdient hat
mehr als das Tausendfache eines
durchschnittlichen Walmart Mitarbeiter
bei allem Respekt dann muss ich sagen
dass ich das nicht für richtig halte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wünsche dir wir wären nie in diese
Lage geraten ich wünschte wir hätten nie
diese außergewöhnlich hohen Vergütungen
gehabt heute mir war nicht klar dass es
soweit kommen würde vielleicht wussten
andere immer ganz genau dass dies das
Ergebnis davon sein würde aber ich denke
das ist bedauerlich und ich bedauer ist
ich glaube man hat irgendwie immer so
ein Gefühl im Hinterkopf dass man nicht
Teil von etwas gute Mist aber ich hatte
keinen klares Gefühl dass ich etwas
aktiv schädliches tue als dann die
Finanzkrise ausbrach begann ich mich
wirklich unwohl zu fühlen und ich fragte
meinen Chef ob die Öffentlichkeit uns
das jemals verzeihen würde also die
Rettungsaktion und er sagte mir nun es
ist so die Öffentlichkeit vergisst immer
die Öffentlichkeit vergisst nach der
Spar und darlehenskrise hat die
Öffentlichkeit vergessen dass die
langfristige kapitalverwaltung in die
Luft geflogen ist die Öffentlichkeit
vergisst immer und die Öffentlichkeit
wird es wieder vergessen und wir werden
weitermachen und es wird wieder alles
normal machen Sie sich also keine
Gedanken darüber in Großbritannien haben
die 1000 reichsten Menschen mehr
Vermögen als die Ärmsten 40% in den USA
besitzen die obersten 0,1% ungefähr das
gleiche Vermögen wie die unteren 90%
[Musik]
ich bin seit fast elf Monaten trocken
das ist die längste Zeit die ich je vom
Alkohol weg war
in Abo und ich habe gelernt dass mein
Spielraum für Fehler sehr klein ist ich
meine wenn ich zu einem Drink greife
fange ich wieder von vorne an
[Musik]
Baby
es gibt einen Plan ein zweites Tor zu
bauen
diese 10 bis 20 Häuser komplett von den
restlichen Häusern zu trennen die jetzt
schon komplett getrennt sind
ich glaube es ist mehr eine status-sache
als seine angstsache es gibt bereits
einen Mann am Tor die Hälfte von ihnen
mit einer Waffe
[Musik]
wir haben ehrlich zu sein würde ich
lieber in Florida Leben meine meiner
nächsten Motivationsschübe wird es sein
dass ich irgendwann nach Florida ziehe
und dort einen Zweitwohnsitz haben
möchte
[Musik]
ich bereue nichts nächste Woche lebe ich
vielleicht unter einer Brücke
aber ich habe es wenigstens versucht
[Musik]
wenn ich Millionärin oder sowas sein
könnte und ein großes Haus kaufen könnte
mit ungefähr 50 Zimmern
dann hätte ich meine ganze Familie bei
mir
das würde ich lieben ich würde es lieben
[Musik]
es ist immer so viel zu tun ich wünschte
ich könnte die Kinder ein bisschen mehr
sehen oder ich würde gerne sagen wir
gehen heute Abend mal essen ich erwarte
nicht viel vom Leben ich wünschte nur
es wäre ein bisschen einfacher
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich werde ich wieder hier
landen aber nicht weil ich in eine
Schule gegangen bin und ein ganzen
Haufen Kinder erschossen habe oder
jemandem vergewaltigt habe oder sowas
sondern weil ich wahrscheinlich beim
Stehlen eines Brotes erwischt werde und
dafür eine lebenslange Haftstrafe
bekomme
[Musik]